Who is the absolute unmatched handsown
barnone worst sinner ever in Islam? Who
is the undefeated, undisputed champion
of evil? Who is the all-time king of
idolatry?
You might think that the answer is
Satan. And you'd be wrong because this
is Islam where Satan always turns out to
be the real hero and someone you might
not expect always turns out to be the
real villain. Watch what happens when we
spend just a few minutes going through
Islam's most trusted sources to answer
the question, who is the worst sinner
ever in Islam? According to the Quran,
the worst possible sin is sh associating
partners with Allah. Surah 4:48 reads,
"Surely Allah does not forgive that
anything should be associated with him
and forgives what is besides that to
whomsoever he pleases. And whoever
associates anything with Allah, he
devises indeed a great sin." Similarly
in verse 116 we find surely Allah does
not forgive that anything should be
associated with him and he forgives what
is besides this to whom he pleases and
whoever associates anything with Allah
he indeed strays off into a remote
error. So Allah doesn't forgive
associating partners with him the sin of
sherik but he might forgive anything
else. Now, how does a person commit
sherk? Well, there are lots of ways to
associate partners with Allah. You don't
have to actually bow down and worship
other gods. Muhammad tells us that if
you simply swear by something other than
Allah, you're committing sherk. If you
say, "I swear on my mother's grave,"
you're guilty of sherk. Let's look at a
few passages from Islam's most trusted
sources. Sah albkari 38:36
narrated Iban Umar the prophet said if
anybody has to take an oath he should
swear only by Allah the people of used
to swear by their fathers but the
prophet said do not swear by your
fathers sahim Muslim 4257
it was narrated from Abdullah that the
messenger of Allah caught up with Umar
bin al-qatab among a group of riders
when Umar was swearing by his father and
the messenger of Allah told them not to
do that and said Allah forbids you to
swear by your fathers. Whoever wants to
swear let him swear by Allah or else
remain silent. Sahim Muslim 4262
it was narrated that Abdul Rahman bin
Samura said the messenger of Allah said
do not swear by false gods or by your
fathers. Sunn Abu Daud 32:48 it was
narrated that Abu Hurerra said the
messenger of Allah said do not swear by
your fathers nor by your mothers nor by
the rivals to Allah. Do not swear by
anyone but Allah and do not swear by
Allah unless you are telling the truth.
There are tons of these passages, but
I'm more interested in why Muhammad says
we should only swear by Allah. Why
should we never swear by anything other
than Allah?
Sunn Abu Dud 32:51.
It was narrated that Sad bin Ubeda said,
"Iben Umar heard a man swearing no by
the Cabba." Iban Umar said to him, "I
heard the messenger of Allah say,
"Whoever swears by something other than
Allah, he has committed an act of
sherk."
So, Iban Umar heard a man swearing by
the Cabba, I swear by the Cabba. And he
rebukes the man for swearing by
something other than Allah. Why? Because
Muhammad said, "Whoever swears by
something other than Allah, he has
committed an act of sherk." Anyone who
swears by something other than Allah has
committed sherk, the worst possible,
least forgivable sin. Putting all of
this together, since the worst possible
sin in Islam is sherk, and since you
commit sherk whenever you swear by
something other than Allah, we have to
conclude that anyone who swears by
something other than Allah is committing
the worst possible sin in Islam. Now
that we understand how sherk works,
let's see what Allah swears by in the
Quran. In the Quran, Allah swears over
and over again by the Quran. Surah 36:2,
I swear by the Quran, full of wisdom.
Surah 38:1, I swear by the Quran, full
of admonition. Surah 43:2,
I swear by the book that makes things
clear. Surah 50:1, I swear by the
glorious Quran.
Allah repeatedly swears by the Quran.
But Muhammad said that when you swear by
something other than Allah, you're
making it a partner with Allah.
Therefore, the Quran is Allah's partner.
It's not very surprising to most of us
since Muslims claim that the Quran is
eternal. They tell us that the Quran
shares one of Allah's attributes,
eternality. So we might expect Allah to
make this eternal book his eternal
partner.
Allah also swears by Muhammad. Surah
15:72, "Verily by thy life, O prophet,
in their wild intoxication, they wander
in distraction to and fro. Allah swears
by Muhammad's life, making Muhammad a
partner with Allah." This shouldn't be
surprising either since Muslims
obviously don't treat Muhammad like a
mere human being or even like a mere
prophet. Draw a picture of Moses. No
Muslims riot. Draw a picture of
Muhammad. Someone has to die. Now it all
makes sense. Muhammad is Allah's
partner.
But Allah has angelic partners too.
Surah 77:5.
I swear by the angels who bring down the
revelation. Surah 79:1, I swear by the
angels who violently pull out the souls
of the wicked. Allah swears by the
angels. But didn't Muhammad say that
when you swear by something other than
Allah, you've set it up as a partner
with Allah? So angels are partners with
Allah. Allah must have been quite lonely
though because he made all kinds of
partners. Surir 81:15 I swear by the
stars. 851 I swear by the mansions of
the stars. 5675 I swear by the falling
of stars. 911 I swear by the sun and its
brilliance. 7432 I swear by the moon.
891 I swear by the daybreak. 8416 I
swear by the sunset redness. 921 I swear
by the night when it draws a veil. 8611
I swear by the rain-giving heavens. 511
I swear by the wind that scatters far
and wide. 91 I swear by this city Mecca.
681 I swear by the pen. 521 I swear by
the mountain. 951-3
I swear by the fig and the olive and
Mount Si and this city made secure.
Wow, that's a lot of partners. At this
point, you're probably thinking to
yourself, "David, if Muhammad says that
swearing by something other than Allah
is sherk, and Allah swears by all these
other things, making all of them
partners with himself, [snorts] Islam
isn't really a monotheistic religion.
It's polytheistic."
If that's what you're thinking, you're
only partially right. Islam isn't purely
polytheistic. And you'll see why in
surah 69 38-39
Allah declares, "I swear by that which
you see and that which you do not see."
Allah swears by that which you see and
by that which you don't see.
Allah swears by everything seen and by
everything unseen. But guess what?
That's literally everything. There are
only two kinds of things. Things that
are seen and things that are unseen.
Allah swears by all of them. This means
that Allah swears by absolutely
everything which makes everything a
partner with Allah. Polytheism is the
claim that there are multiple gods.
Pantheism is the claim that everything
is God. So Islam would be more
accurately described as some kind of
polytheism. pantheism hybrid. Think
about this for a moment. Allah swears by
what you can see.
You can see a pig. So Allah swears by a
pig. Muhammad says that when you swear
by something other than Allah, you've
made it Allah's partner. Hence, Allah
has made a pig his partner. Not
according to me, according to Muhammad.
I'm just following Muhammad's claims to
their logical conclusion because his
followers never do. You can see pagan
idols, so Allah swears by them, making
them his partners. You can see a bottle
of whiskey, so Allah swears by a bottle
of whiskey, making a bottle of whiskey
his partner.
You can see me and the apostate prophet
and Robert Spencer and Tommy Robinson
and Hatun Tash. So Allah swears by all
of us, making all of us his partners.
You can't see Jai and Doo yet, but Allah
swears by the unseen, too. So Allah
swears by Jai and Doo, making Jai and
DOC his partners. Why do you complain
about us so much? How dare you complain
about Allah's partners?
Allah swears by everything seen and
unseen. He swears by Zionists and by
atheists and by Muhammad cartoons and by
dogs and by toilets and by what's in
toilets.
And when Allah swore by all these things
from all eternity in his eternal
partner, the Quran, he associated all of
them with himself, thereby committing
more sherk than the worst Meccan
polytheist could ever dream of. But it
gets worse because according to the
Quran, the more knowledge you have about
right and wrong, the greater your guilt
if you sin. In Surah 2 verse 22, Allah
commands, "Do not set up rivals to Allah
while you know." While you know, i.e. if
you know better. This is why Muhammad's
companions who started off as pagans
could be forgiven of their sherk. They
didn't know any better. The more
knowledge you have, the more responsible
you are. But Allah's knowledge is
supposedly greater than anyone else's.
Which means that Allah knew exactly what
he was doing when he set up literally
everything as his partner. Since Allah
has the most knowledge and since he's
committed the most sherk, he is by far
the worst sinner who's ever existed
according to Islam.
Muslims, if you don't agree with this
conclusion, you need to tell me where
did I make a mistake.
My entire argument is based on two
facts. Fact number one, Muhammad said
that swearing by anything other than
Allah is sherk. Fact number two, Allah
swears by literally everything. Allah
swears by the Quran and by Muhammad and
by the angels and by the California
angels and by the California raisins and
by sun-made raisins and by the sun that
makes them and by the moon and by moon
pies and by cowpies. Allah swears by
everything.
So tell me who's wrong. Was Muhammad
wrong when he explained sherk? If so,
what else was he wrong about? Or is the
Quran wrong when it says that Allah
swears by everything seen and unseen?
I'd like to know. Because if Muhammad
and the Quran are both right, then Allah
has committed more sherk than anyone
else ever. And since shik is the worst
possible sin and Allah can't appeal to
ignorance, that would make Allah the
worst of all sinners and the most guilty
of all sinners.
My goodness, how will he ever forgive
himself?
Do you know what the Muslim response to
this is? I know because I've asked them
about it.
The response is, "Well, the rules don't
apply to Allah. For instance, Allah can
command you not to kill, but that
doesn't mean that Allah isn't allowed to
kill. The rules he makes don't apply to
him."
Great. So, Allah tells us not to commit
sherk. But he can commit all the sherk
he wants. In fact, since Allah's rules
about sherk don't apply to him, he can
spend all day every day bowing down to
pagan idols and worshiping them. He
tells us not to do it, but the rules
don't apply to him. So Allah is free to
be the supreme king of all pagans if he
wants. Make sense?
This is a pattern I've been noticing in
Islam. On the surface, some of Islam's
teachings seem appealing. Believe in one
God, pray, fast, give to charity.
Awesome. Where do we sign up? But as
soon as you dig a little deeper, you
always, always, always find blasphemous
nonsense.
Believe in one God who happens to be the
worst sinner imaginable according to his
own prophet.
Pray to a god who commits more sherk
than anyone else according to his own
prophet.
Can't sign up for that.
Does anyone else keep getting the
impression that Islam is really from
Satan masquerading as God and that
because he's Satan, he can't stop
bragging about himself?
He's like a forger who makes a forgery
of a famous painting,
but he can't resist adding his own
signature
because he's just too proud of his
masterpiece.
[music]
>> You just back on me. This is a power of
religion. There's a reason to it.
[music] Yeah. Yeah.